Welcome to Hadley Freeman,
uh,
author of life moves pretty fast and various other things.
Uh,
so very warm welcome to you.
It seems we're in a room,
at least with,
uh,
people who haven't read the book yet.
Uh,
so I wonder if you could just start by giving us a brief precis of what it's
about and why you wrote it.
Right.
So this book,
uh,
who to her about almost three years ago now is a bout eighties movies,
which I love very deeply,
and it's not just a nostalgia fest because obviously you can turn on channel
five any night and see loads of utterly random talking head,
just going,
oh yeah,
mannequin.
It's amazing.
Oh yeah,
that's the future.
It's amazing.
Obviously that is,
those are all true,
although my actually quibble with the medication.
But what I wanted to write about is how these movies from the eighties movies,
these movies from the 80s teach us lessons that we don't get today.
And that is because actually Hollywood was weirdly very liberal in the 80s and
they were able to do really interesting things with movies that we don't get
today.
So,
for example,
depicting abortion on screen in a positive light or having a black act or take a
role that was written for a white actor.
Um,
and all sorts of things like that,
depictions of masculinity,
um,
movies made about,
and just for women,
all those things were coming out of the 80s and we don't really get those
anymore.
Okay.
So that's sort of why you rate it.
One of the things that strikes me most when reading it is just how much fun it
seemed that you were having so much fraud.
Where's that genuinely real or are you just really skillful at writing as if it
were that much fun?
Well,
there was a lot of angsting beforehand.
Once I had this idea because my publishers were really not into it.
They just thought nobody buys books about movies,
which I quibble with almost all my bookshelves are filled with books about
movies and eighties movies,
bit passe.
Now.
Does anybody really care about that?
And I just knew they did.
I knew they did.
All my friends love eighties movies.
I love eighties movies and I very much live by the maximum you should write
about what you're interested in.
Not trying to guess what other people are interested in,
which sometimes doesn't always work for lay readers would say from the Guardian.
But I believe if someone is passionate about their subject,
that really comes through.
And so I asked it a lot,
but how am I going to do this?
And I thought,
how do I sell this to people?
Did it?
And then I just thought,
stop worrying about it.
Stop trying to convince your publishers.
Just write the book you want to write.
Write the book you wanted to read.
Which is always what I say to aspiring writers when they ask,
you know,
how do they find their voice?
So what,
what should they be writing about?
I just say,
right where you want to read.
And I just thought I'm going to write what I want to read.
And it was so much fun.
And the more I wrote in,
the more I spoke to friends about it and the more enthusiastic I saw.
All my friends were at,
my parents' friends were and other people are getting really into it and saying,
Oh my God,
you've got to talk about,
obviously you know the 10 best montage is and you've got to do,
you know,
the 10 greatest power of is everybody had all these lists,
ideas for me and obviously you're going to have to include the lost boys and the
this and the that.
And I thought,
Oh wow,
people really are into this.
And then I had,
then I suddenly got a burst of confidence and then it was so much fun to write.
Well I think we can,
we can see,
even if it weren't for the book,
by stranger things and ready player one,
there is so much almost pen touch nostalgia for the ATC.
Yeah.
Which,
and that really wasn't around as much when I was writing it because I was
writing it in 2014 you mister,
you created that.
I created it.
I don't think,
I think I'm part of it,
which is,
I don't mean like I'm anywhere on the same level of stranger things,
but I'm,
I have this idea that there's a 30 year rule,
which is it,
that it takes 30 years.
So people still look back on a decade with nostalgia and that's because kids who
grew up in that decade are now adults and they're now making the content and
they're looking back at you.
I see.
That was what was great and they're putting it out there.
So I'm very much of that generation that is putting it out there.
Cool.
So let's dive straight into specific films and specific messages that you've
taken out of them.
Um,
I'm going to start with Ghostbusters because I watched it all last night.
I was meant to be writing a book and I thought,
I'm eating healthy.
I'm going to watch you guys buses.
Hello it.
Indeed.
Awesome.
Um,
and it,
it's aged pretty well.
It's amazing for the most part.
Yeah.
Um,
so you bring out this as,
uh,
almost male role models of friendship.
Yeah.
Um,
and obviously as soon as he started talking about the eighties,
Ghostbusters,
you think 2016 Ghostbusters,
how would you compare them in terms of,
uh,
does the reboot,
whatever you want to call it,
of Ghostbusters,
portray female friendships in the same kind of way?
Or was it more extreme?
I mean the,
the friendships in original Ghostbusters are reasonably extreme and non non
normal that there's,
there's a certain truth there.
There is.
And also obviously with part of the time of eighties,
Ghostbusters is,
it is,
it was so based on their real life friendship,
particularly I'd Bill Murray and Dan Akroyd,
uh,
who were friends from Saturday night live.
And in fact,
Dan Akroyd originally wrote Ghostbusters for him and his best friend John
Belushi,
uh,
who died in the middle of John Belushi literally writing,
he wrote a line in the script.
He got a phone call saying the John Belushi had overdosed in Beverly Hills.
Um,
so he was writing it for the two of them.
And you can sense that friendship.
And Harold Ramis was a close friend of theirs as well.
And I really feel you can have that feeling that these guys all know each other
to love each other and appreciate each other's weirdness.
You know,
they all called Bill Murray the murder Cain and obviously Harold Ramis then made
other movies and deck.
We've made other movies with Bill Murray and Harold Ramis obviously then make a
groundhog day with Bill Murray.
And they had a very complicated friendship.
They're all like always falling out with each other.
It was a very weird time to be a very successful male comedian in the 80s,
but I feel that all comes across and you sense that despite the weirdness,
they'll love each other truly.
Um,
and now I had so much goodwill towards the 2016 female Ghostbusters.
First of all,
I love the idea of women carrying a great franchise.
I really love Paul Feig that he's the one who's championing this idea.
He's the one who directed it and I believe her,
the screenplay for it.
I think Melissa McCarthy,
Kristen Wiig,
all good things and it just completely didn't work,
which was disappointing.
It was a bit like watching Hillary Clinton's presidency bed.
It was just like you really want it to work and it just,
it didn't work.
Um,
and I think so many of the things that were wrong with it exemplify what's wrong
with movies.
These kind of big movies today compared to the 80s,
I mean for a start,
it was all filmed on studio lots.
So the whole city looks really anonymous and generic.
You don't really get a sense of where on earth these people are.
Whereas in the 80s,
Ghostbusters,
it's very much New York City.
Like they are on the New York streets.
They're going to tavern on the green.
This restaurant in central park,
which is where Rick Moran has,
has his freak out when he's turned into the goal.
Um,
you see the taxi's going around the corners,
the piles of garbage,
Larry King on TV.
And there's a specificity about that obviously in New York public library that
is very charming and people then sense that this is real.
This is real.
It definitely helps.
And if you grew up in New York as I did,
but I feel you're watching this,
you're like,
okay,
this is real.
I mean,
I watched Ferris Bueller when I was like eight,
so when I first saw it and I'd never been to Chicago,
I didn't go to Chicago until I was an adult,
which is weird cause I only lived in New York,
but I liked that they were all in the streets.
They were going to the museum,
they were going to restaurants.
Like I got a sense of Chicago.
It wasn't just some generic studio lot that could be used for a sitcom the next
day.
Um,
and there was no rough edges to the 2016 Ghostbusters.
I mean Bill Murray and the original Ghostbusters is really freaking weird.
I mean he was like giving electric shocks to the teenage boy when it opens.
It's latching on everything.
He's basically stalking a Sigourney weaver and the movie accepts all that and
isn't excusing it.
And in fact she's making fun of his face to it,
whereas I didn't,
you don't get that as much.
It felt more try hard,
but they were trying to do with the characters there.
Um,
and I mean,
first of all,
I really don't,
I think it's a mistake to try to reboot such a beloved movie as Ghostbusters.
I mean even Ghostbusters couldn't do it in the 80s when they make those posters
too and everyone got cross about it.
Uh,
so I don't really know why you would do that.
Why not just make your own new movie?
Right.
Which I guess at the same time we have,
uh,
if,
if we're looking for strong women needs,
et Cetera,
we have wonder woman.
Hello.
It's an old movie too.
I mean that is piggy backing on another old franchise,
which is fair.
It's true.
Which is fair.
Um,
but people will always have sentimental feelings about little movies.
I mean,
I feel like that is the wrong way to rehash eighties movies the right way is to
do something like stranger things,
which kind of digest all these eighties movies and make something totally new
through them without then having people my age and older being like,
Ooh,
as good as the original cause it is original.
It's just doing all these amazing homogenous to stand by me and alien and all
this cool stuff.
So that brings me to TV in general.
Uh,
you go in detail in the book into the economics of why films aren't made in the
same way,
why things like dirty dancing just wouldn't get meet them at all.
Um,
but it feels to me like interesting things are happening on TV.
Definitely.
I mean that is where things are happening now and I don't necessarily think
that's a bad thing.
I do think you lose something from not having that big go to the cinema,
but I know I sound like I'm sitting in my rocking chair on a porch talking about
this,
but I remember the weekend Batman came out in 1989 and to the movie theater with
my dad and it was such a huge deal.
I mean probably you guys all weren't even alive then,
but it was such a big deal when this came out.
Like this movie had been building up all summer.
You go to the cinema,
there's all this Batman Logos and Signia everywhere.
I'd always say at the time,
grown up like this,
this is discussing and so commercial before a kid,
this is amazing.
And I felt like really collective experience sitting in the cinema watching Tim
Burton's Gotham city,
you know,
seeing Jack Nicholson.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
And you don't have quite that same feeling watching something on TV.
You just don't and you don't,
it's not even about who the glory of the cinema.
It's more that everybody's watching things at different times now and it's,
it's more of an individual experience rather than a collective experience.
I guess.
All the,
uh,
thinking about when Handmaid's tale was on.
Yup.
That would,
I would watch it without being able to breathe barely until the adverts and then
suddenly checked with Twitter.
You see everything,
there's a sort of different,
yeah,
it's a different elective experience.
It is.
You know,
Judd Apatow,
um,
talks very sort of sentimentally I think in the book I use the quote where he
talks about going to the Ghostbusters when that opened,
going to go,
suppose his movie and standing in the line around the block.
And yes,
this does sound like we're all talking about going to drive ins in the 1950s or
something.
But there is something to gain from that and there is something else to be
gained from watching things on TV and like tweeting about it with your friends
and seeing what Armando Iannucci is saying about something that you just watched
and other people who you like Sharon Horgan,
whoever.
Um,
but I think there's something sad about the kind of,
it was really kind of a slow death of big cinema really.
Cause that is what I grew up with.
Yeah.
I,
I think it'll be interesting to see what happens to cinema in the next 10,
20 years with more and more great stuff coming on TV basically.
Yeah.
Which they're not even trying to compete with because they're too scared to
compete with really
occasionally cinema is we'll show TV series at the cinema and that sort of
sounds a strange,
strange situation going back to the lessons that we should have been learning.
Um,
it feels,
yeah,
the title is the lessons we learned as if it job done.
We don't need to talk about those things.
We've,
we've learned now,
I'm pretty sure you'll agree that a lot of these lessons haven't been learned.
No,
that's right.
Is there any one in particular that you think we really need,
is that one of these films that you should say,
great,
this should be on the curriculum.
Everyone should just get the message.
I mean,
I as a,
as a woman in feminist,
all the rest of it,
I mean,
I would say dirty dancing.
Really.
I do think dirty dancing is an amazing movie and people particularly not wanting
to gender stereotype,
you're a particularly,
men tend to laugh at me when I say that.
Um,
I've yet to meet a man who's ever seen dirty dancing willingly and not been
forced yeah.
By his girlfriend or wife.
Absolutely.
Well,
I come to Google,
everything is here,
um,
at,
but it is an incredible movie.
It's a movie about the importance of legal abortion.
Um,
which is what I,
Eleanor Bergstein the screenwriter wrote it to be,
she wa she felt in the 80s that women were taking feminism and,
um,
access to abortion for granted.
And that Roe versus Wade was under threat.
And so she wanted to write a movie for teenagers that stress the importance of
it.
And so she took this movie,
set it in,
I believe it's the end of the fifties and sixties,
isn't it?
That must be the fifties,
um,
where abortion was still illegal in America.
And there's a character in the movie who gets pregnant and has to have an
illegal abortion and then has to be saved by Jennifer Gray or a character called
baby.
Jennifer grade's dad who's a doctor.
And this is really just like slid into the movie.
I mean,
obviously when people think of dirty dancing,
they think of Patrick Swayze holding up dinner for gray and the leg and you
know,
the two of them having sex and all the cool songs on the soundtrack.
I mean,
and that is what you're supposed to see.
But she buried this subplot in it and made it so essential to the movie that no
one could take it out.
And the studio of made it,
the producers at first didn't have any problem with it.
And then I'm a pimple cream.
Wanted to sponsor the movie and they saw it and they're like,
oh,
we can't have this abortion thing.
And Eleanor Bergstein was like,
oh,
what a shame.
Because the movie kind of hangs on it.
You can't really work without it.
And they're like,
okay,
fine.
And in the end of the movie made so much money that obviously didn't matter that
it wasn't sponsored by Bimbo Green.
Um,
and the really sad thing is,
um,
recently some high,
we're producers went back to Eleanor and said,
we'd love to remake dirty dancing obviously,
and are they,
and she was like,
great.
And they said,
but we're going to take out the abortion thing.
And she said,
no way.
And what she did instead was she rewrote it for the stage and you guys might
have seen this in the west end,
the dirty dancing musical,
which she did.
And she owned up the,
um,
the abortion subplot and emphasized about how the doctor really could have gone
to prison for helping a woman who'd had an illegal abortion and was dying on a
table from internal bleeding and really made it very central in the play.
I mean it's you,
you can't ignore it in the play.
And it in a way,
the movie,
you can almost overlook it in the plate.
We really can't.
And that movie has made almost a billion dollars around the world.
Um,
which just emphasizes how cowardly and wrong Hollywood movies are now.
I mean,
you try to think about a movie that depicts abortion now.
Okay.
So the obvious one would be Juno that was made came out about 10 years ago now
in which abortion is depicted unbelievably negatively.
Like so negatively,
even though this is a school girl,
I think it's like 15 in the movie who is not in a relationship that needs to do
something when she's pregnant and she goes to the abortion clinic,
it's dirty,
it's CD.
The woman at the reception desk is like kind of licking this lollipop in a
salacious way.
Um,
and in the end,
the character do know,
um,
is,
uh,
who's played by Ellen page,
of course,
is persuaded not to have an abortion because an abortion protest or tells her
outside,
you know,
your baby has fingernails.
Now,
there are a lot of reasons a woman could have choose not to have an abortion.
I mean I have two children myself,
so obviously there was a period of my life when I chose not to have an abortion.
I'm not saying everyone who's pregnant to have an abortion,
but you cannot have an abortion protestor.
Use a stupid argument like that and on screen show that as that's okay.
Like that's not,
that's not okay.
Um,
particularly since the movie was written by a self professed feminists,
Diablo Cody and stars one Ellen page.
And I find it really upsetting that.
No,
but I no point in this did they think this is not right to do this?
You interviewed Alan Page about
that.
Did you also interview the,
the writer and sort of why?
Why'd you chose to write it down?
But I did,
I,
I did interview her and I,
I said to her,
I don't understand why you depicted abortion so negatively in this movie.
You could have just had her say,
do you know what?
I actually want to have this baby and give it to a couple who don't have a baby.
That's a perfectly reasonable reason not to have an abortion.
And she said to me,
any woman who doesn't think I'm not doing enough for feminism can kiss my butt.
And you're like,
that is not a response.
That is not a response.
Yeah,
that's just not a response.
That's a stupid response.
Um,
and then knocked up was the other obvious one in which a woman gets pregnant on
one night stand,
she's 22.
She's just got her dream job being a TV host and she rejects flat out not having
a,
not having an abortion,
which is fine.
Maybe a lot,
you know,
a lot of women would do that.
It seems unlikely in that circumstance that a woman in la who just got her dream
job would reject having an abortion but fine.
And the only character who mentioned it to her is her mother.
And the mother is styled in the movie as basically horrendous.
And the mother says to her,
just get it taken care of.
And one day you'll have a real baby.
Now,
obviously that's a terrible way to put it.
That's a terrible way.
And nobody who is pro choice as I am would say it like that,
just say,
because your choice,
it doesn't matter.
You know,
it's your life.
Do you want to be looking after a baby or just say,
do you want to have a baby right now?
You're 22.
You don't even know this guy's name.
Like,
seriously do you want have a baby?
And she goes,
yes I do.
Actually,
you know,
it feels important me.
Then you say,
fine.
Where you don't say is just,
just get rid of it.
It's disgusting.
It's not a real baby.
Anyway,
that's all the way people talk about abortion.
So between junior we've got uh,
a pro life campaigner who's giving bad reasons and then we have a pro choice
person.
He came back,
he's getting above reasons.
We need a more mature,
there's nation positive way and there's only been one movie.
That's what he dealt with it,
which was a small independent movie called obvious child,
which came out I think in 2016 starting very excellent Jenny slate.
And which is about a girl who gets pregnant.
Well not girls.
Twenties is a woman who gets pregnant after a one night stand,
but the thing is,
the whole movie is about her decision whether or not to have an abortion and
they then show her,
you know,
the camera's over,
she's on the garnish she size to and there's like tears rolling down her face,
anything,
you know?
Sure.
Some women really do feel this very strong way about it,
but for a lot of women now,
they don't.
They don't.
And for love,
I mean I had an abortion when I was 24 I'm very happy talking about it and it
was just a relief and everybody in here will know somebody,
whether they know it or not,
who's had an abortion at this point.
It's not,
it doesn't have to be depicted as the seismic thing in someone's life.
It is just something that happens and you take and you deal with it.
Whereas in eighties movies,
yes.
Something like fame,
which everyone forgets had an abortion in it and which a girl in the school gets
pregnant and she's white and he's black already.
You cannot imagine this happening in a movie today.
And she just goes to the clinic.
It's done.
And then she goes back to the school.
Fast Times at Ridgemont high,
1980,
I believe Amy Heckerling written by 18 old Cameron Crowe,
a 14 year old,
played by Jennifer.
Jason Leigh gets pregnant.
She had to take him to the clinic by her older brother,
played by the much loved much miss judge Reinhold.
He picks her up afterwards,
they go home,
she goes back to school.
I mean that these are just making abortion part of life,
which is what it is now rather than making it either a big deal or a terrible
deal.
And do you think that it was acceptable to do that in the 80s because society
was different because people weren't paying attention to what was going on in
the films or just because Hollywood was bullet?
Um,
well two things.
I think people weren't paying as much attention.
I think also movies were able to be riskier.
Those movies that I mentioned,
fame fast and for is my dirty dancing.
We're all made fairly cheaply.
They were seen as mid range movies,
so they weren't required to make $1 billion back right away,
which is what movies now our movies are not marketed around the world.
It costs $1 billion tomorrow can move you around the world.
So every movie that comes out that gets a big release like that has to be
basically transformers or something that doesn't need a lot of translation that
isn't going to upset people in China,
which is a massive market now and isn't going to have set the Christian right in
America.
So things are much blander,
everything specific is taken out,
everything real is kind of taken out.
And that's why movies today feel very bleached.
And is that just Hollywood or is it the global film industry?
It's mainly Hollywood is mainly because it's mainly Hollywood movies that get to
go around the world.
I mean,
you know,
the French film industry doesn't spend $1 billion sitting with is around the
world generally.
Um,
but also Hollywood underestimates things a lot of the times.
So Hollywood is now when in the 80s,
a movie made 80% of its money in America,
20% overseas,
and now that's flipped around.
Um,
and in some ways you could say that's good that Hollywood is aware that the rest
of the world exists,
but it does mean that they have these weird assumptions about what people in
China like to watch.
Um,
so they'll say,
well,
you know,
in China we can't have,
they're not gonna go see a movie with a female lead and they're not going to
have a movie with a woman on the poster.
And there are loads of examples online.
You can look at it through a website called Google,
um,
of which movies that had female women,
a female women had had female actors are women on the posters in America and
Britain that have men on the poster in China.
You know,
they do this also with black and white actors.
So like 12 years a slave.
For example,
I had Brad Pitt on the poster when it went overseas.
I mean,
it's like there's a lot of that.
But actually if you look at the Chinese film industry,
a lot of their movies do have female leads.
They do take much riskier things.
It's just that America,
it's just like,
whoa,
we can't ignore the Chinese.
We have to be really careful with this.
So he's blood pump.
It'd be really interesting to know what happens with Black Panther because
actually the last movie that made a lot of money overseas that had an all black
cast was coming to America in 1989.
Uh,
it'd be amazing if Black Panther can kind of restart that again 30 years later.
I wasn't sure whether we should discuss this as two white people talking about
racism has never great look.
But just briefly in the book you talk about Spike Lee and Eddie Murphy having
very different ways of empowering African Americans,
different ideologies about it almost.
Um,
whether you make films that are about black communities or
you have black people in white communities like Eddie Murphy in several films.
Maybe the only bucket to,
yeah.
Um,
and it struck me thinking and got through that argument how Hamilton has kind of
done something interesting to take a third position.
Yeah.
Right there.
Um,
do you think that's something that works to compromise on those two positions or
is it just,
it would either spike Lee or Eddie Murphy be happy with what's happened there?
Or do you think they still have an issue?
I don't think Eddie Murphy's that happy about anything these days,
which kind of breaks my heart because he really is my favorite of all the 80s
actors.
Um,
but I think spike Lee would kind of love it.
Surely Hamilton.
I mean,
I hope most of you have seen Hamilton.
It is amazing as you watched it,
when you first see it,
you're just like,
Whoa,
Thomas Jefferson is a black guy.
And then you're like,
he would literally don't even see it at like within five seconds.
It's amazing.
Um,
I'd say it almost goes in reverse.
So,
um,
in fact,
I bought this copy of the book on my way to see Hamilton in December.
And then in February I went to Hamilton grange in New York.
And solve various pictures of Hamilton and Jefferson and all these people.
Well,
they're white.
Yeah,
they're all tight.
It was really all white.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
And he's suddenly think back on other plays and movies you've seen,
you're like,
that's so weird.
Everyone was white in them.
Like that's the total,
right.
That's such a weird casting decision.
Anyway.
Anyway,
so you,
so Eddie Murphy's whole thing was he was going to infiltrate the mainstream
Hollywood industry in a way that no black actor had been able to before and
Richard prior had been to self destructive to do so before,
uh,
and then make movies from within and kind of recreate the system from within,
which he successfully incredibly successfully did.
And you know,
it,
it's a testament to his talent that he did that because a black actor pharmacy
needs to be like 10 times more talented than a white actor to get a role.
And he was a million times more talented than everyone and he was the most
successful action of the decade.
Whereas Spike Lee was all about giving a voice to the black community and the
black media.
He was going through at the time was still making things like she's gotta have
it and all those kind of movies.
And they were absolutely polar opposites.
And Eddie Murphy as the decade went on,
got increasingly attacked for this,
about the black by the black community,
feeling like they,
that he'd abandoned them,
that he was making,
you know,
Beverly Hills Cop and the golden child.
And when she's basically the only black guy in it and making movies for white
audiences and not reflecting the black experience.
And he became more and more kind of embittered and kind of drew more and more
into himself.
And then he may coming to America,
which is an incredible movie in that it has an entirely black cast and no white
audiences seem to notice that in America.
And if anyone of you know anything about racial history in America,
that really is kind of a miracle.
Um,
and then after that he,
he started,
started doing more of that.
So like boomerang,
he did in the 90s in which he sort of gave,
you know,
launched Chris Rock,
but he became angrier.
I kind of sad or you know,
anyone who has the kind of success that he did so quickly need,
it's going to screw up your brain.
Um,
and Spike Lee,
I mean,
he,
I think spike Lee is just incredible.
I mean,
you know,
his movies from the eighties and nineties or some of my favorite,
but he found himself being painted into this tiny corner that he couldn't really
break out of.
But if you look at the early nineties,
there were so many amazing movies about African-american's particulate,
people like John Singleton and Boyz in the hood and stuff like that,
that,
uh,
you don't see any more today.
And I personally believe that it was the combination of Eddie Murphy and Spike
Lee together that kind of helped that era of the nineties nineties movies of
African American cinema.
Cool.
Once you
take away from politics entirely for just briefly,
what are the things I love that you say is that the princess bride,
which was one of my favorite films ever,
uh,
works brilliantly because it is,
it is a fairy tale and it's a spoof of the fairytale,
much like into the woods.
That's fine for a fairy tale as a musical and an absolutely awesome musical.
Um,
various films have tried to do this and some succeed and some really don't.
So for me,
ones that succeed,
the frighteners is a great uh,
sort of horror film and Spoof Horror Film and starship troopers manages to work
in various different ways.
I remember I was at university when starship troopers came out and I was in the
fourth year and have various friends in the first year and titanic was out at
roughly the same flame and all of my first year friends said,
Oh,
I love titanic.
It's so deep,
no pun intended,
but starship troopers is just mindless violence on all my fourth year friends
were going,
wow,
starship troopers is very,
very cutting.
Titanic is extremely dreary and it worked for me.
And then you've got films like scary movie,
which are very explicitly trying to be a spoof.
And again for me it doesn't work.
What do you think is the key to getting that?
I feel that the filmmaker has to really love the genre.
I mean,
another one I would add into that that's quite like that is Mars attacks and I
know people kind of have mixed feelings about Mars attacks.
I am a big Tim Burton Fan,
as you might've guessed at this point.
And I feel like you get that.
He really loves that genre of that kind of Schlocky alien movie.
Obviously like Edwood whole thing.
Like he loves you to return from planet nine and he's kind of any is sending
that up but also doing it.
Um,
and with the princess bride William Goldman who wrote the original book,
which I highly recommend if any of you haven't read it,
it's so amazing.
Obviously knew those books from meeting them to his daughters at night.
I mean he said he wrote the princess bride because his daughters loved
princesses and brides and they loved books about them and he'd just combined the
two.
And he knows those stories and he also knows those kind of pretentious academic
approaches to them,
which is what he makes fun of in the book.
A little bit like possession by ais by it as well.
That kind of making fun of this kind of academic attitudes towards literature,
which is what he does.
You have to love the genre.
You can't hate it.
And I feel like the scary movies and the scary movie movies,
does that make sense?
Um,
they're just kind of,
there's sort of hating on it.
They're just making fun of it and you have to have love for it.
And I feel like,
and I don't mean to keep mentioning this TV show with stranger things,
you feel the love,
right?
It's not just like making fun of eighties eighties hairstyles and eighties
music,
like normal homages to 80 stuff.
Just take the silly surface.
You have to have a deeper feeling.
And with princess bride,
you get the deeper feeling.
It's not just like,
oh,
princesses screaming in a tower and dragons,
you know,
it's like,
there is like deeper emotions going on.
Fantastic.
Yes.
But to the politics,
that's how I was thrilled.
Uh,
yeah.
I started reading the book thinking,
Hey,
this is a book about movies.
I then thought,
hey,
it's another feminist book.
I mean just finished a bunch of feminists or he taught me,
it's pretty fast.
It's another,
yeah,
you have the Magnolia test.
Before I go further,
Georgia described the magnolia tests.
Gosh,
now,
you know,
you described them.
I really was actually,
you'll to do it better than me.
You owe us so long since I wrote the question,
but it's,
it's about a strong women led a that depicts,
depicts women doing awesome things and tends to have,
and this is the bit that I want to talk about.
Um,
men who are really not much,
we'll say either they're explicitly despicable or they're just a bit useless.
Yes.
Um,
do you have any good examples for Allah isn't just men who want to be decent
human beings?
Oh,
for sure.
For sure.
A strong women led films that depict men not in a romantic role,
but being decent human.
Um,
yeah,
so obviously the Magnolia tests is,
I was,
I'm sure you've all guest named for Steel Magnolias,
which is my favorite women's movie of all time.
And any man who's like,
oh,
I don't want to say we've got Lisbet old women.
You're so wrong.
It's like one of the funniest movies ever read one of these that I haven't seen
yet.
I mean,
no.
Again,
like dirty dancing.
No man has ever willingly electricity steel magnolias it was written by a man I
should add and is a true story about his sister.
But anyways,
that's a whole other issue.
Um,
my favorite movie that depicts platonic male,
female friendship is say anything.
Um,
I'm amazed by how few people in this country,
I've seen it in America.
It's like such a major teen movie.
It's,
you know,
up there with dirty dancing or whatever or you know,
breakfast club,
um,
say anything is so great.
So it's how many,
many of you seen it?
Most of you probably have it.
Just a fee.
Oh my God.
All of you guys need to go home.
Not just guys like guys,
girls,
everybody just go and watch it right now.
I excuse you from what?
For the deck.
It's about John Cusack
in his dorm crew sock as well.
No,
no.
Oh my God.
Oh my God,
it's junk.
He's at his most junk cues.
Okay.
It's his ultimate role.
Like,
forget about gross point blank and grifters,
it's like the ultimate cues that girl who's in love with the,
he's like the sort of weird kid in high school whereas it trench coat and stuff.
Um,
and he's in love with Ione Skye,
who's like the class princess who's right,
beautiful at her father is played by John Mahoney,
the recently deceased father of Frazier.
As y'all probably better know him as who is wonderful in it.
Maybe.
So it's about donkeys I trying to get with Ione Skye,
but in the background he's got his two best female friends called DCN Corey,
one of whom is played by the immense Lili Taylor who is amazing.
And you're watching this movie and the opening scene is them talking and like
the three of them obviously have an incredibly close,
they're very similar.
They totally get each other,
get each other's music.
They like go shopping for guitars together and everything.
And what has we mean thinking if you know,
surely he's just going to get with one of them.
In the end he's going to forget about this princess,
but no,
no.
Like they just want him to be happy and he just loves hanging out with them
because as the movie shows,
his male friends at school,
one of whom is played by Jeremy Piven,
um,
are just total idiots.
Um,
play by Jeremy Pivot,
let's just reiterate that,
uh,
who are just total jerks and he gets his most fun with his female friends and
it's a wonderful depiction of male,
female friendship.
And I went to a coed school for sixth form and I was like,
yeah,
that is what it was like.
Not all men and women who get on then have to sleep together.
Right.
That's a very nice message to get from a movie.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And it's sort of almost the UNCW message of when Harry met Sally.
I know,
I know.
Although I do feel like,
I mean they did not ready,
but it is true.
It is the antiemetic of that.
But there is also the cross friendships there,
you know,
with Bruno Kirby and Carrie,
Carrie Fisher,
like they are all hanging out and they're not all sleeping with each other.
It's like some mass orgy.
Anything that has Carrie Fisher just gets my version.
Exactly.
Exactly again.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
It feels like I have no idea what the time is,
but it feels like we've been chatting away.
Sorry,
I talked so much.
Very quiet.
Extremely Needy for me.
Other people may have questions and I'll just interject more.
Yeah.
Uh,
first I wanted to add the comment.
You said that one day TV,
Charlottesville,
Bertrand and cinema,
uh,
they are shown in the cinema,
for example,
game of Thrones wash on the same amount,
but of course like it must be a spectacle,
but about politics and all that stuff.
What is your,
how to say,
how do you,
what do you think about forcing diversity in cinema?
What,
what do you think about scandal in Academy Awards about not enough black actors
and all that?
What do you think about it?
Say,
what did you say?
I mean,
I write about it quite a lot because until the guardian stopped,
being able to send me to La for the Oscars is very sad.
I used to go to the Oscars every year.
It's right about it.
And of course it's,
you know,
I think it's good for it to be drawn to attention.
It's not like I think there should be quotas,
but I do feel like the academy should be shamed into the fact that,
you know,
are so few black winners of Academy Awards.
It's is amazing.
So few women directors have been nominated or won awards.
It's,
it's,
it's mortifying.
Um,
and this should be done to center.
And the problem is,
is that the academy is very largely old white men.
You know,
there are many statistics about it and they just see themselves,
you know,
they look for themselves.
Okay.
But,
uh,
what about just the last black actors in other say work in?
No,
there's no,
but I mean,
it's never going to be 50,
50,
but there's obviously it should be more,
I mean,
there've been there plenty of incidences of African American actors just being
completely overlooked.
I mean,
Eddie Murphy,
how was Eddie Murphy not won an Oscar?
I mean,
he clearly should have won an Oscar at this point and we'll just have this,
the same thing about Dick Opera until about about Djakapurra.
Yeah.
Well.
Well,
he did witness Oscar though.
I mean,
he got there.
Um,
and I,
I mean,
I'm sorry.
I,
I genuinely believe Eddie Murphy is like one of the greatest actors around.
I mean,
he got nominated for dream girls.
I personally would have nominated him for Bowfinger,
which he is incredible.
And it,
all of you need to see that too.
Some eighties moving to nineties movie.
Him and Steve Martin,
I mean,
Eddie Murphy's performance in that is just like astonishing.
Um,
and as he said,
I mean,
if you could Google Eddie Murphy,
you can Google Eddie Murphy.
I'm speech at the Academy Awards.
It's so hard not to do that.
Um,
in which he talked about this and the ade saying,
well,
you guys gave an award to a black actor last year.
I can't remember who it was.
Maybe Denzel Washington,
so you don't need to do it for another 30 years.
Right.
And it's like,
yeah,
that is literally how it works.
That is looking out,
you know how white,
you know Greta Gerwig,
why is she not overlooked,
you know,
for best director,
it's stuff like that.
You just think this is ridiculous that it's these old white male movies that win
all the time.
Okay.
Hi.
Um,
do you think Netflix and Amazon getting into film production is going to cut,
revive this kind of a tradition of being a bit edgier?
No question.
I hope so.
I mean the film festivals are really freaked out by it as far as I can tell.
A lot of them refuse to show Netflix and Amazon prime productions,
which is just ridiculous.
You can't fight against what is happening.
I don't know how Netflix and Amazon prime,
I have so much money.
Probably you guys in this room can enlighten me on that.
But they are making really amazing stuff now.
I mean the conversation I hear with my friends,
but it used to be like,
what are you going to go?
Are you going to see like in the cinema this weekend it's now,
have you seen that new Netflix documentary?
I mean that is how people talk to each other.
That's how,
you know,
I've got two very young children,
so I met home most evenings and my boyfriend and I all we do know is what stuff
on Netflix and Amazon prime and stuff that they've made original content.
We're currently watching the defiant ones,
which is amazing,
which is the documentary about Jimmy I,
I,
and adopted.
Right.
I should have been keeping a list,
you know,
this is the stuff we watch now.
It's not,
it's not going to the multiplex on Friday night anymore.
Some world has changed.
But one interesting thing,
uh,
to come back to films,
I was thinking about films that I have found,
not necessarily edgy,
but,
uh,
have at least promoted more diverse,
well view,
um,
and engaging young people politically,
I think tend to be around either superhero or superior.
Like if you think that even if you didn't elect sort of the remake of
Ghostbusters,
you can think it's kind of super hero ish.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
By the time we've got wonder woman and Black Panther.
And at the same time,
young people,
certainly in America,
I think over in the UK as well too.
To slightly lesser extent appeared to be more politically aware.
Yes,
no question.
Is there a correlation,
causation?
And it may be,
I mean,
it's certainly true that superhero movies have been good at smuggling in good
roles for women and ethnic minorities.
They have,
there have been good at that and you know,
and Ghostbusters,
one of the specific things was to,
you know,
improve the representation of,
this is a terrible way of putting it.
The black ghostbuster.
I mean,
one of the big faults with the original Ghostbusters,
how Ernie Hudson is so sidelined in it,
like for no reason either have a minute or don't.
Um,
and in,
uh,
oh Leslie,
um,
what is her name?
Who plays her?
And uh,
the new Ghostbusters,
I forgot my mind's just gone blank.
Can someone Google it for me anyway,
but she has a real role in it and she's in it,
the whole movie and she's not pushed out.
Um,
and that is great.
That was great.
And definitely young people.
I don't know if young,
I don't know if it's because of superhero movies that young people are more in
line.
I think young people always need to go further than the generation before and
young people are going further in this than we did.
Right.
Another thing I find interesting about para fins,
Z,
you talked about Batman,
uh,
as sort of,
even though it was kind of dark in a way,
it had huge light moments.
Tim Burton or that's in Boston one.
Yep.
Um,
so yeah,
big gothic feeling,
but still hugely funny bits.
Yeah.
And when you wrote the book was before I think before Deadpool.
Yes.
It was definitely before Thor.
Ragnarok yeah,
that's right.
Um,
do you feel that things are taking an upswing?
I think so.
And it's weird,
like I've seen actors like Chris Pratt or whoever get more in these kind of
roles and they are funny.
Yep.
Rather than,
you know,
tortured,
Christian Bale and tortured Tom Hardy with a mask on his face.
I mean,
I don't,
I honestly like do you guys are like those movies,
I didn't laugh at them,
whereas we recently rewatched right.
Drug addicts.
It's very funny.
No,
it's true.
I mean,
I loved,
um,
the,
the moderate,
the Christian Bale Batman with the joker.
I mean,
that is a great role obviously with heath ledger as the joker,
but it's not fun watch.
I mean,
it's quite heavy weather really watching it and everything's so dark.
not just like,
like mood.
I mean the lighting,
you can't fucking say anything.
Whereas you watch Tim Burton,
I mean,
it's so much fun.
And you know,
watching,
watching Jack Nicholson do his little dance down the steps towards Kim
Bassinger,
he's playing prince on his boombox.
So much fun.
And it looks like a cartoon.
It doesn't look like it's taking yourself so damn seriously.
And it doesn't have the constant car chases.
Like you have the Christian bail bond and the Christian Bale Batman's,
I don't mean to keep knocking them.
Obviously.
They're beautiful and they're kind of done in this amazing way.
Christopher Nolan is obviously an incredible filmmaker,
but there's just too much.
There's,
there's just too much.
I feel there's too many characters,
too many people being tortured,
emotionally tortured.
You know,
you have Gary Oldman,
you're Christian Bale,
whoever the villain is,
you have this and the that and fuck.
Yeah.
By the time you get to Datto Rises,
oh my God,
it's so,
it's still a lot for a very long,
it's so long.
And a vendor is that just too
much?
They like pack in so much in these movies.
Whereas I feel like with Tim Burton's Batman,
you have just nice clean Michael Keaton a bit unhappy in a castle.
Some villain.
Yeah.
Oh there's an angst amongst in a quite interesting self mocking way like you
know,
kind of,
he knows he's this pathetic rich boy.
Like feel sorry for me.
Rich boy hours.
Christian Bale is just kind of like miserable and you're like,
this is great.
Night out.
Do we have any other questions?
So it can be slightly to self indulgent.
And I used to work in children's publishing and they went once to a marvel
showcase.
And I was really excited because I'm a big marvel fan.
And,
um,
I remember being incredibly disappointed because they had this huge cinema
screen in there,
were showing all their new films and then it came up in massive letters.
Everything we do is to,
and I was just really excited for it and it said to sell more product.
And I remember
what,
yeah,
what's happening to cinema today,
that they want to basically make everything so PG 12 so they can appeal to as
many people as possible.
And that's why I think films like that man don't work anymore because they're,
they're darker and they're older and everything feels like a little bit safer.
And we don't have many eating's anymore.
I remember when I used to go to the cinema,
I used to sneak into eighteens all the time and it's no like there's no
eighteens,
everything's really dry.
Um,
and everything's trying to sort of sell more product and merchandise.
And I wondered if you shared that.
I mean definitely everything's trying to sell merchandise,
but I,
you know,
you have to kind of blame eighties movies for that.
I mean it was the eighties movies that really got onto that.
Obviously star wars in the 70s and then Batman in the 80s and Ghostbusters.
But I don't feel like they were just made for that.
They weren't seen as vehicles for that.
It was the merchandise came off the greatness of the movies.
And actually the merchant does kind of took those movies by surprise.
I feel.
Um,
whereas now the movie is almost a side show to everything around it.
You know,
there's just not as much effort put into scripts anymore is for me the real
problem between movies today and movies from the 80s.
And that's because so much of a movies takings comes from overseas that they
don't want to have movies,
they have complicated scripts that need,
um,
a lot of translation where things have cultural references that won't translate
overseas.
Um,
which is why it's movies now.
Like,
for example,
the Christopher Nolan Batman are so full of car chases and shootouts and special
effects.
Cause obviously you don't need to translate those.
I mean,
whereas you have something like,
uh,
you know,
going back to Tim Burton's Batman is there's a lot of dialogue going on in those
movies,
whether it's like in the newspaper office or whether,
you know,
it's,
uh,
Bruce talking,
you know,
having the long conversations with his Butler and these kind of weird parties
that he had.
There's like emotional stuff that needs translating and it's just too much of a
faff and like,
why bother,
you know,
big CGI effects,
um,
work well anywhere.
Although I personally find them incredibly tedious.
One of the things I love about go especially is how charming the special effects
are there.
So shonky,
uh,
and now when you see,
when I see special effects in a,
I went to see the re the modern jungle book,
I'm watching the actors thinking,
I know you're just standing against a blue screen.
Like that's all that's happening here.
You feel no real connection between what's going on the actor and the special
effects.
I don't think,
um,
and I think that's something that's been lost,
but that's what translates overseas.
I have a question.
Do you also have lessons that we shouldn't have learned from?
My goodness,
of course.
So obviously eighties movies for all I'm talking about Eddie Murphy,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
We're completely,
totally racist,
which is why it's amazing that Eddie Murphy was such a success,
which is why another reason why everyone should just,
you know,
worship his talent.
Um,
if you look at,
I mean,
let's see,
is the worst eighties racist movies.
I mean,
where to even begin.
Obviously there are 16 candles,
which is John Hughes,
his first film with Molly Ringwald who's upset because her parents have
forgotten her 16th birthday.
What an innocent sweet movie you might think.
Ah,
but let me tell you about their random Asian exchange student called Long Duck
Dong,
who just wants to have sex with a white girl and does things like fall out of
trees at inopportune moments.
Um,
there's also this unbelievably weird bit in 16 candles where the boy who,
um,
who my room was in love with,
is talking about how his girlfriend has passed out at a party and he could have
quote unquote had her five times without her noticing and then tells the school
nerd he's played by Anthony Michael Hall.
Um,
why don't you just got in the car and have sex with her?
And it doesn't say in those words because why don't you go upstairs?
And he does.
And then the girl wakes up next to this Dorky guy and she's like,
did,
did we have sex?
And he goes,
uh Huh.
And she's like,
oh,
hi.
Like it's the most weird thing in the world.
And eighties movies are full of that kind of stuff.
I mean,
those kind of movies don't get it.
They haven't lasted so well.
Things like Porky's risky business is something that everyone remembers very
fondly as like this movie in which Tom Cruise dancing in his underpants.
But actually if you watch it,
it's a movie about how a boy who turns becomes a pimp and that becomes a pimp.
And then gets into Princeton because of it.
Cause a Princeton guy comes to his house to meet Tom Cruise,
who is now fully a pimp and probably sleeps with the hookers that he keeps in
his house and then get them into Princeton.
It's the weirdest movie you'll ever see in your life.
I swear to God.
Um,
so there's all that obviously.
And also,
you know,
racism against black people is so obvious in eighties movies.
I mean,
Eddie Murphy,
his first film is 48 hours,
uh,
in which he's opposite McNulty.
And Eddie Murphy plays this Khan who's led out of prison to help grizzled carp.
Nick naulty find criminal ring,
if I remember this correctly.
And I was actually supposed to,
Richard Pryor,
who is in the moon,
who is supposed to be in the movie,
but he was too much of a disastrous,
they cast Eddie instead.
Now McNulty is playing the traditional grizzled cup.
Um,
you know,
a bit alcoholic has woman problems are,
and as part of his term in grizzled nest,
he is incredibly racist.
And he calls,
um,
Eddie Murphy,
things like watermelon.
But if you a spear chucker like unbelievably racist terms.
And at no point is this seen as like,
oh,
maybe we shouldn't like this guy.
It's seen as part of his charming on reformed,
grizzled Innes and Eddie Murphy was asked about this in a couple of interviews,
like,
what is this not a bit weird for you to be doing?
And he's like,
well,
you know,
because my character is kind of equal with him,
it's like it makes it okay and you're like,
no,
it makes it okay.
Is that Eddie Murphy is such a charismatic actor that it doesn't,
he doesn't feel totally subjugated by it.
He's able to,
like,
he's out acts and McNulty and steals all the scenes,
but when you watch it,
you're like,
this is disgusting and why am I supposed to be cheering on this grizzle racist
cop who being totally racist?
Um,
so there's obviously tons of that.
and also when you look at Eddie Murphy's movies,
I mean,
I don't,
I'm sorry to be going on about Murphy.
It does happen.
Um,
he was,
he was not allowed to do very much within them,
really.
He was,
I mean,
even when he was making them.
So you look at Beverly Hills cop for example,
which was a movie that was written for a white actor in incredibly,
it was supposed to be Mickey Rourke who was in it and then it was,
was to be Sylvester Stallone and then to Don Simpson.
And um,
uh,
Jerry Bruckheimer is enormous credit who,
who are producers.
They did something that never been done before,
which is they decided to cast a black actor in a white characters role.
And the cast Eddie,
yeah.
When you're watching this,
it's very notable that Eddie Murphy is not allowed to have sex really at any
point in this might be there.
He has this white female friend in Beverly Hills who works in the art gallery.
I'm sure all of you have seen Beverly hills cop.
You know the girl who works in the art gallery with it.
She's got that,
you know,
assisting with the funny accent.
Uh,
Bronson Pinchot and there are lots of seeds where this girl was like sprawling
on his bed in the hotel room.
They're like hanging out in hotel rooms.
They're like old friends and clearly in the original script they were getting it
on.
But no way is this happening in the movie.
No way do you see Eddie Murphy ever kissing a white woman and these movies?
Um,
I see it.
You can sense the restrictions that were on black actors.
Definitely.
And this is Eddie Murphy who is the most powerful actor in the 80s.
So stuff like that.
And of course the Ernie Hudson thing.
And Ghostbusters is totally weird and unacceptable.
And I say that as someone who loves Ghostbusters is almost more than life
itself.
Yeah.
Various films with,
uh,
with my kids.
So we have kids who are 14,
11,
11.
This is a great film.
Ignore that.
They enjoy that bit to know that unfortunately they ignore that.
Really unfortunate.
It's funny,
John Hughes made quite a few weird,
they racist movies in his kind of slapstick thing cause he,
he came from a real sort of slapstick,
uh,
sort of tradition.
So his movies like the National Lampoon vacation movies,
which he wrote,
um,
are so bizarrely racist.
So there's this one scene,
I think it is in the first one,
national lampoon vacation.
Chevy Chase,
um,
is driving his kids to the inner city,
which I mean,
you know,
he lives in the suburbs starting to get to the inner city,
which obviously means a street full of black people and their car stops at a
light.
I think at this point.
And loads of black people just swarm in and start stealing their hubcaps.
And in all of Hughes's movies,
I love Hughes.
Ferris Bueller is lifting my favorite movie of all time that the representatives
of black people is makes you just kind of want to throw up on your shoes.
Um,
like weird science for example.
I've done,
how many of you have seen weird science that also a terrible movie and lots of
ways.
I mean that's kind of the only other time you see black people in a John Hughes
movie.
I'm trying to think of any others.
And it's when Anthony Michael Hall goes to a jazz club and their loads of like
jazz black people or being kind of creepy and jazz and like that's it.
So in John Hughes is world black people or they're stealing your hubcaps or
basically smoking reefer and being a bit creepy.
Um,
so yeah,
lots of bad stuff,
but also lots of good.
Katie,
you mentioned you have a couple of young children.
Have you given much thought to what their introduction to [inaudible]?
It's all I think about,
it's really tied to like,
so um,
I have two year old twins.
Um,
so they don't really have attention span for anything beyond a two minute Peppa
pig video at the moment.
But,
so they're twin boys as well,
which is obviously slightly different from me.
Although I,
you know,
I very much think that boys and girls just watch the same movies.
There shouldn't be these kind of limits,
but I do get that certain things grab boys' attention quicker than maybe grab
girls' attention.
So for the,
my first movie from that year that I saw was I believe Ferris Bueller's day off,
whereas I already know my boyfriend stuff like the first movie 80s movie they're
probably go see is going to be like back to the future or Indiana Jones.
Like those kinds of more actiony things.
Whereas I got,
I got to this little bit late and obviously I loved them.
There was no difference.
There shouldn't be a,
definitely both boys and girls watch.
Let me just stress that.
But I do think they'll probably enjoy back to the future earlier than they might
enjoy.
Ferris Bueller and the breakfast club.
So important question about introducing kids to films,
Star Wars.
Do you start with a pursuit for,
or do you start with at a certain point it gets so confused with the episode
numbers at this point?
It's kind of,
I think you've got to start with episode four,
right?
I mean,
actually my first star wars was return of the Jedi.
I think that might've been the first movie.
I saw it in a cinema.
It was return of the Jedi tricks and really funny and I loved it because I love
the eworks obviously.
So I was well down with that and they changed the music for the rerelease.
Very weird.
Um,
but yeah,
so I,
I make plus all the time about eighties movies,
I'm going to,
I've already got like a stockpile of DVDs of what the kids are gonna Watch.
Um,
so yeah,
so back to the future,
Indiana Jones very much so.
Um,
Ferris Bueller,
which I believe they will truly love at some point and so on and so forth like
that Iti,
obviously 18 might be the first one even though I think my,
my kids got a bit bored by eating,
but love Ferris Bueller love.
But you know,
I was scared by ut and when I saw,
I think I saw when I was at seven and I just thought it was disgusting and I was
like,
why is this weird kind of tree trunk living in this little girl's closet?
It's horrible.
So
I know,
I know.
Can we talk about Ferris Bueller a bit more please?
So you talked about how uh,
it's an interesting depiction for one thing.
I love your take on it as a sort of fantasy,
which suddenly explains things and it's one of those,
yeah,
why didn't I think of that?
But it talks a lot about class.
Yes.
And I find the whole class and wealth divides in films interesting.
Particularly because it seems to be an international differences as well.
And I see it almost more in soap operas actually.
So in the u s there's Dallas and dentistry and Australia,
there are sort of middle class home and away neighbors.
Well I could run in them and hope it away.
I remember when I moved here it was like they ran a trailer park.
Like I can't remember what their names were at home in a way,
but they literally ran for overlay here eastenders
well,
exactly.
So there's no difference in middle class.
Upper middle class in Australia is Australia.
And then we have east enders and Coronation Street.
And if you look at a lots of the UK film industry output,
things like bras off billions up,
it tends to be more working class.
Um,
and we'll focus on the class divide more.
Yeah.
So I find it interesting how Ferris Bueller's day off focuses on the class
divide between sort of upper middle class and really,
really rich A.
Yeah,
I'm sort of feels like wealth as a sort of proxy for structure versus agency.
Yes.
Which I only found out or learned about as terms reading girls will be girls by
Emory tool.
So very good.
Awesome.
Awesome book.
Go read.
What films should have watched to talk about structure versus agency?
I mean the most to me,
the most obvious film about class is actually cited earlier.
John Hughes film,
which is pretty in pink.
Um,
which is very much about working class kids versus the rich kids.
Don Hughes himself was lower middle class and he grew up in an upper middle
class neighborhood in the suburbs of Illinois.
So he was always very self conscious about class differences.
And in his movie the rich kids are always kind of evil and the poor kids are
noble.
Um,
but the rich kids get everything and the poor kids have to struggle.
and what he made,
Ferris Bueller,
he kind of recreated that but made ma so pretty in pink.
There's a character ducky played by Jon Cryer who is very working class,
sleeps on apparently a mattress on the floor and,
and seems to not have any parents.
Um,
and he is up against the horrible rich kids in school,
played by James spader ultimate crush.
Um,
who's this kind of awful drugs taking up noxious guy called Steph for some
reason.
Oh characters and John Hughes movies have really weird names.
I one day I want to do a decision,
I want to go back to school and do a Phd dissertation on the kids names,
kept the names of kids and John says movies.
Anyway,
so there's stuff.
So anyway,
ducky is kind is unpopular because basically he's poor.
Like that's kind of what pretty in pink is sag.
And the same for Molly Ringwald character.
Andy,
she's unpopular because she's poor.
She literally lives on the wrong side of the train tracks.
They have her living next to a train for God's sake.
So when he came to write Ferris Bueller,
he sort of rewrote ducky,
but as a fantasy and he got Matthew Broderick to play the character of Ferris.
Now,
Matthew Broderick and Jon Cryer as teenagers look basically identical.
It's kind of amazing in the parade scene.
Exactly.
I mean,
he went with a quiz.
I mean he's basically ducky.
Um,
but he made Ferris Bueller upper middle class,
um,
and lives in this big house.
And he made him exactly like Ducker.
He likes weird British bands.
He wears weird two tones,
shoes.
He knows about tech.
He's quite annoying,
but everyone loves him.
And
Raul at read the room,
Freeman,
um,
and um,
but they make it really popular and everyone in the town loves him.
And so it's kind of ducky slash John Hughes.
His fantasy of what he could have been like,
what life could have been like if he'd been rich and he could've skipped school
and gotten away with everything.
If he stayed off from school sick,
they'd be banners in the sky saying,
get well soon.
All that kind of stuff is a real teenagers fantasy of popularity.
And for John Hughes,
popularity and wells were synonymous.
Um,
I think it is interesting when British people see American movies that show
social class device because British poverty and American poverty in a lot of
ways are really different.
A really interesting illustration of that,
for me,
it was when I went to see Blue Valentine a few years ago in this country where
some friends are Blue Valentine starring Michelle Williams or Ryan Gosling.
I'm sure a lot of you have seen it.
I mean,
they're supposed to be quite poor in that movie.
I mean that's part of the movie is that are struggling with money,
but they always have massive cars and I didn't even notice this when I stopped,
when I came out.
My,
my best friend is bread.
It was like,
they're so poor.
Why are they driving these massive four by fours?
As I see in America,
obviously there's a whole thing about American,
like basically,
I don't even know what they call it now.
We've had leasing cars and P in American suburbs,
everybody has these massive cars that they lease and they're going for.
And that's not saying brief poverty in American poverty like American.
I don't know.
It's not like American people are poor,
British people are in poor.
It's just a different attitude towards,
so a lot of times in these American movies,
I feel like British people see the people with massive cars and think,
oh,
they're not really poor.
And actually it's a whole different kind of weird poverty system in America.
Anyway,
that's a different,
different things but also the big houses in these movies.
That's another thing that,
that I find British people find really weirded out by particularly the suburban
houses and John Hughes movies.
Like you look at the house in home alone.
I mean that house is like as big as it seems like as big as the White House.
I mean that houses fricking massive.
Um,
but the truth is in the suburbs,
um,
they are probably very expensive now,
but there are a lot of bigger houses that don't necessarily denote massive
wealth that they would,
especially here in the countryside.
I mean,
you can't get these big houses in the suburbs thing.
They find that don't,
that don't require you to be a billionaire.
Brilliant.
I could chart with you all day,
but unfortunately we are running out of time.
Does anyone have one final question for Hadley?
I've got to go back and write a column about Ben Affleck.
So please help me fill my day with questions.
I use movies.
Anything anything's better than better than bath flag
in that case remains for me to say
thank you so much.
This has been a complete treat.
And all of you who haven't read the book yet,
have a treat in store and do book next week off cause you will want to just
spend the whole time watching films.
They go home and watch,
say anything.
Certainly going to be on my list.
I spent,
uh,
a happy,
very happy plane journey having just finished the book for the second time
watching I think four of the movies in here on one day.
It was awesome.
So thank you ever so much.
Complete.
And Yeah.